alors mon amour alors c'était bientôt
spectacle je te présente le dr come-back
c'est le papa de lennar qui dans la même
classe que canon caruhel elles sont très
amis je crois oui ils s'entendent très
bien
cela ne me parle que de kalinka bonnes
vacances monsieur qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
côté téléphonie autopsie d je voulais
m'assurer que tous se posent plus arrête
de mentir qu'est ce que tu as fait que
les gars étaient comme maffliers jamais
j'aurais pu le faire le moindre émoi ce
repas
bonjour je saurai ce que tu as fait à ma
fille
je vais demander la réouverture de
l'enquêté
même si vous avez raison sur le fond
votre plat n'a aucune chance d'aboutir
je vous en prie aidez moi ce que le
meurtre de ma fille ne tombe pas dans
l'oreille
en fait seuls les messieurs c'est vous
qui êtes et j'ai en faisant mal votre
travail c'est une euros
il faut s'attaquer this et tous
vous êtes un sorcier on se fait pas
justice soi même monsieur bamberski
tu t'imagines des choses tu es devenu
fou
rejoints et céréales cette folle et un
jamais tant que tu pense à toi
kalinka
elle ne vendra pas
et